there are so few Jedi left
[Music]
she's coming
our enemies are multiplying
a galaxy is not safe
could use the help it's now or never
once the rebel always a rebel
hunt them down this is where it gets
interesting get ready ready ready
Ahsoka two episode premiere August 23rd
only on Disney Plus
[Music]
always two there are no more no less
a master
and an apprentice
be mindful of the living force young
parallel
[Music]
you will be tempted by the dark side of
the Force
One Must Destroy in order to create
faster it's been a while things have
changed
sometimes we have to do what's right
fronting fear is the destiny of a Jedi
buckle up never be afraid of who you are
that
um but you have learned
we have what they grow beyond
that is the true burden of all Masters
Ahsoka two episode premiere streaming
August 23rd on Disney Plus